with Tony Stark and Peter Parker working
together in the MCU you can bet your
favorite web shooter we're going to see
some alternate costumes in these movies
let's have a look at some alternate
costumes at the real Peter Parker aka
the Peter Parker of the marvel 616
universe has actually worn and why
obviously the first one is from amazing
fantasy number 15 in 1962 this is the
original spider-man costume but the
first one isn't really the one year
remember while the first one is
technically on the cover we actually see
a proto spider-man costume the Peter
Parker designs for wrestling this one
includes slacks a white tank top and a
web mask it would only be later in the
issue that we would see the famous red
and blues which includes an underarm
webbing and also some kind of dots in
the white area it's inconsistent with in
the issue but I think it was only used
for dramatic effect in the moment we
never see it again
after this it's classic red and blues
from here on out until amazing
spider-man number 100 1971 when we have
the amazing six arm spider-man thanks to
a genetic experiment the Peter Parker
performed on himself to try and rid
himself of the spider powers instead he
grew four additional limbs for his
troubles an amazing spider-man number
113 in 1972 Doctor Octopus and
spider-man fought and destroyed
spider-man's mask and he had to go into
a costume shop and replace it
unfortunately as many of us know the
costume version is never really quite
like the original and in this case it
had eye holes cut out of the mask and a
couple of other odd enhancements slash
changes in Peter Parker spectacular
spider-man number 40 in 1980 due to an
experiment with dr. Curt Connors aka the
lizard spider-man became a half man half
lizard with enhanced spider powers the
lizard portion took control of his body
and began terrorizing New York City
thankfully dr. Curt Connors was able to
manufacture an antidote
amazing spider-man 213 and 1981 Peter
Parker attempted to wash a spider-man
costume overnight in the solution that
he created himself when the suit emerged
from the bath was washed out with pink
typical Parker luck in Peter Parker
spectacular spider-man number 66 in 1982
Peter Parker fashioned an anti electro
suit made of an old air mattress which
would protect him from Electro's
electricity powers in 1984 most of
Earth's Mightiest Heroes were kidnapped
and taken to a far-off planet called
battle world it was there that
spider-man and his comrades were forced
to battle some of Earth's greatest
villains and in secret Wars number eight
mistaking one piece of alien technology
for another spider-man discovered an
alien costume which responded to his
thoughts and commands in amazing
spider-man 258 1984 Peter Parker
discovered the alien costume was
actually an alien symbiote that wished
to bond with him permanently in the home
of the Fantastic Four they used a sonic
gun to remove the costume and trap it
but a left Peter Parker kind of naked
and afraid
thanks to some quick thinking on the
human torch's part spider-man was given
an old Fantastic Four uniform and a bag
to put over his head and for good
measure there was also a kick me sign on
his back he returned to the classic red
and blues until Peter Parker spectacular
spider-man number 99 in 1985 when his
girlfriend at the time black cat offered
him a threated version of the black
costume claiming it was much more sexy
than the red and blues in spider-man vs.
Wolverine in 1987 Peter Parker found
himself in Germany and without a costume
not learning his lesson about
aftermarket spider-man costumes he
picked one up which actually said does
fine on the back which in German
translates to the spider in 1990 Peter
Parker was imbued with the awesome and
seemingly limitless power of Captain
universe but it wasn't until amazing
spider-man 329 when he actually changed
his costume to Captain universe after
being exposed to gamma irradiated
pincers in a battle with the Hulk
Peter Parker transforms into a spider
Hulk in web of Spiderman number 70 after
an intense battle with the newly formed
and inter-dimensionally enhanced
sinister six
spider-man is seriously injured but in
spider-man 21 in 1992 thanks to
interdimensional help he's given cyber
robotic enhancement which accelerate his
healing factor in spider-man 25 in 1992
in a battle with our cave net team up
with Excalibur spider-man is temporarily
imbued with the power of the Phoenix and
becomes Spider Phoenix in spectacular
spider-man 206 in 1993 Peter Parker's
mask is yet again destroyed but this
time in an attempt to preserve a secret
identity he borrows black cats and it
looks just tear built from an actual
modified webbing formula Peter Parker's
own design
I'm the spiders steel or steel spider
was created in 1993 in web of Spiderman
over 100 I think it lasted two pages in
an intense battle with typhoid mary and
spectacular spider-man number 214 in
1994 spider-man's mask is ripped yet
again this time uses tattered remains to
make a ninja mask out of it here's where
things get a little bit dicey in web of
Spiderman number 118 and 1994 during the
Clone Saga thought to be clone
Ben Riley seemingly returned from the
dead and donned a makeshift spider-man
costume which was called The Scarlet
Spider the reason it works in this list
is because not only has Peter Parker
himself worn this costume to cause
deception but there was a little bit of
confusion back then about who the real
Peter Parker actually was in spider-man
58 1995 Peter Parker was in a hurry and
not having any time to change costumes
through on the black costume spider-man
masks gloves and just his regular old
Peter Parker clothes and jacket in
spiderman funeral for an octopus number
two in 1995 peter parker dons doctor
octopus's famous technology to quell a
supervillain uprising in sensational
spider-man number zero in 1996 Ben Riley
is revealed to be the real Peter Parker
and as such creates a new spider-man
costume for a new era during Ben Riley's
run as spider-man in amazing spider-man
410 and 1996 he comes in too close
proximity to the carnage symbiote and
becomes spider-carnage an amazing
spider-man 425 in 1997 the newly
returned Peter Parker teams up with
x-man to battle electro and as such
requires an electro proof suit to fight
him those webs are more than a means of
conveyance in Peter Parker spider-man
number 89 in 1998 when his mask is
destroyed and requires a new one made
entirely from webbing this one's a
little bit of a cheat but in Peter
Parker spider-man number 19 1998
spider-man enters the negative zone
and while in the negative zone his
costume is inverted Makana causes a
really neat-looking effect thanks to a 5
million dollar bounty on his head
spider-man had to go into hiding during
identity crisis in 1998 but great powers
still commands great responsibility and
spider-man needed to go into action but
not a spider-man in spectacular
spider-man number 256 spider-man dons a
familiar paper bag over his head and
fights crime as the bombastic bagman an
amazing spider-man for 33 he donned a
green hoodie in order to battle mr. Hyde
I'm sorry green hoodie that's it
an amazing spider-man 434 we met the
first member of the slingers known as
ricochet in sensational spider-man 28 we
met the iteration of spider-man's
costume known as the Hornet in Peter
Parker spider-man number 91 we met dusk
and all-black the fair and in
spectacular spider-man 257 we saw
spider-man's alternate costume known as
prodigy okay now I know I said no
alternate realities but to be fair in
house of M in 2005 Wanda Maximoff turns
the regular 616 Marvel Universe into the
House of M universe so I think it's fair
to say that the house of M spider-man
costume first appeared in house of M
spider-man number one in the lead-up to
civil war in 2006 an amazing spider-man
5:29 we debuted Tony Stark's custom iron
spider suit for spider-man to wear
during the Civil War during spider-man
Big Time Peter Parker had access to a
lab funds and lots of privacy
took advantage of all three to create
many different iterations of the
spider-man suit including three
different stealth suits one of which was
shall we say
commandeered by his newly cured clone
Kaine most of them appeared in amazing
spider-man 650 in 2010 in amazing
spider-man 6 56 in the no one dies story
arcs vitamin into battle and emotionless
villain known as massacre and had to Don
a bulletproof suit to do it an amazing
spider-man 682 in 2012 during ends of
the earth spider-man debuted an anti
sinister six armor which he used to
battle every single member including Doc
Ock in 2013 when Doctor Octopus took
over Peter Parker's consciousness and
superior spider-man number one we saw
the first iteration of the superior
spider-man uniform but it wasn't until
superior spider-man number 14 that we
saw the second iteration which included
mechanical arms and a design that looks
suspiciously like an Alex Ross movie
design from long ago after Peter Parker
regained control he went back those
classic red and blues but in 2015 we saw
the debut of an all-new all-different
amazing spider-man
an amazing spider-man number 1 now this
list doesn't even begin to cover the
alternate realities and different evil
spider-man and symbiotes that we could
possibly cover but I think the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has a lot to choose
from even from this list alone let us
know what your favorite costume was in
the comment section down below and be
sure to check us out over on comic pop
net but don't forget to Like and
subscribe and check out more stuff from
comics explained